bonjour à tous aujourd'hui un nouvel
épisode de sociaux classiques qui
prolonge et complète un peu l'analyse du
dernier épisode de sociologique sur les
réseaux sociaux dans game of thrones et
on va revenir sur quelques points qu'on
avait laissé en suspens en particulier
sur l'utilité du capital social dans la
sphère économique
l'intérêt de ces analyses de type petit
monde s'est en fait d'essayer de mieux
comprendre comment se détermine l'accès
à certaines ressources pour les
individus grâce à leur réseau social
dans l'expérience de milgram c'était
simplement comment réussir à faire
passer une lettre et ça peut aussi être
comment réussir à trouver un emploi
il ya plusieurs recherches qui ont été
faites pour essayer de déterminer
comment se déroule la circulation de ce
type d'information dans les réseaux
sociaux et j'en parlerai notamment dans
un autre épisode avant de commencer
quelques petits rappels de rigueur en
sociologie
la notion de capital elle est très liée
à la figure de pierre bourdieu et il
faut vraiment la comprendre comme une
ressource à savoir mobiliser pour faire
partie de l'équipe des gagnants dans le
grand jeu de la domination sociale
bourdieu liste trois grandes formes de
capitaux le capital économique
c
m
sortez
des pièces le capital culturel
[Musique]
et le capital social
bon en fait il y aurait une quatrième
forme de capital qui serait le capital
symbolique mais ça on en parlera quand
on parlera des parts sont charlot dont
parlent maintenant
alors du coup ce qui nous intéresse ici
c'est la notion de capital social
bonjour le capital social ça désigne
simplement l'ensemble des relations que
l'on peut utiliser comme des ressources
pourraient tout à fait précis la
définition de bourdieu du capital social
c'est ça le capital social et l'ensemble
des ressources actuels ou potentiels qui
sont liées à la possession d'un réseau
durable de relations plus ou moins
institutionnalisée d'interconnaissance
et d'inter reconnaissance ou en d'autres
termes à l'appartenance à un groupe
comme ensemble d'agents qui ne sont pas
seulement dotés de propriétés communes
susceptibles d'être perçue par
l'observateur par les autres ou par eux
mêmes mais sont aussi unis par des
liaisons permanentes et utile ces
liaisons sont irréductibles aux
relations objectif de proximité dans
l'espace physique géographique ou même
dans l'espace économique et social parce
qu'elles sont fondées sur des échanges
inséparablement matérielles et
symboliques dont l'instauration et la
perpétuation suppose la reconnaissance
de cette proximité à dubourdieu dans le
texte
ça a toujours quelque chose d'un peu
émouvant oui alors si par émouvant tu
veux dire
savourez la sensation évidemment
délectable de sentir de la purée de
cerveau liquéfié dégouliner promptement
de ses oreilles on peut effectivement
parler de prose émouvante
d'autant que ça va le capital social
c'est pas une notion difficile à
expliquer c'est juste la capacité à se
faire des potes et là encore il y avait
un point après une phrase de seulement
dix lignes estimez vous heureux
cela dit on va pas s'éterniser sur
pierre bourdieu parce que si c'est
effectivement l'un des auteurs qui a
largement popularisé la notion de
capital social ici en fait assez peu
intéressés
de fait sur les trois formes de capitaux
qu'il a étudiés c'est surtout au capital
culturel qu'il a consacré l'essentiel de
sa carrière
et c'est surtout à ce capital là qu'ils
imputaient la plupart des mécanismes de
la reproduction sociale
en fait plus qu'une ressource à part
entière ce qu'il dit c'est que le
capital social à
tendance à dériver du capital économique
et du capital culturel
il écrit que quoiqu'il soit relativement
irréductible au capital économique et au
capital culturel posséder pour un agent
déterminée ou même par l'ensemble des
agents auxquels il est lié le capital
social n'en ai jamais complètement
indépendant du fait que les échanges
instituant l'inter reconnaissance
suppose la reconnaissance d'un minimum
d'homogénéité objective et qu'il exerce
un effet multiplicateur sur le capital
possédait en propre
non y'a pas à dire je sens qu'ils
essayent de venir entre eux clamé mais
vraiment rien qui passent en moi qui
suis content j'ai pas en fait pour
simplifier ce que dit bourdieu c'est
qu'en règle générale on a tendance à se
faire des amis dans notre propre groupe
social et que du coup on a tendance à se
faire des potes qui nous ressemblent
c'est ce qu'on appelle l' homo fini et
par voie de conséquence le capital
social ne nous permet pas vraiment
d'accéder à des ressources différentes
mais il a plutôt un effet multiplicateur
sur le capital économique et le capital
culturel propos cède déjà temps je
comprends pas le coup de l'effet
multiplicateur
ce qui veut dire c'est simplement que
les différentes formes de capitaux donne
accès à des ressources différencier par
exemple si tu veux intégrer le club des
propriétaires de yachts
bat a pas le choix il faut que tu aies
du capital économique et les autres
formes de capitaux ils vont pas t'aider
là il faut du flouze al'inverse si tu
veux être l'invité principal d'un cycle
de conférences sur
l'institutionnalisation de la marche à
pied en allemagne à la fin du 19e siècle
bon bah t'as intérêt à avoir fait de
trois charges avant et là c'est
clairement ton capital culturel qui va
compter 1 le capital économique ça va
pas t'aider à rentrer dans le cycle de
conférences bref chaque forme de
capitaux apporte des avantages et des
ressources spécifiques mais justement le
capital social
non quand tu seras à ton club de yacht
tu vas juste être en contact avec des
gens qui ont autant de capital
économique que toi et à linverse quand
tu seras à ta conférence sur l'histoire
de la marche au 19e siècle
tu vas être en contact avec les gens qui
ont autant de capitale culturelle que
toi du coup en te mettant en relation
avec des gens qui te ressemble le
capital social
il n'apporte pas vraiment de ressources
nouvelles il ne fait que
s'y plier l'occurrence des capitaux que
tu possèdes déjà ah ben voilà là j'ai
compris la prochaine fois commence
direct par les exemples je pense que les
logorrhées verbales de bourdieu dans le
texte on peut s'en passer
bon ok je vais essayer mais pour le coup
c'est vrai que le truc de l'effet
multiplicateur il se vérifie pas mal
empiriquement en 1988 il ya françois
héran un sociologue qui a mené une étude
empirique dans lequel il a étudié les
différentes formes de sociabilité
d'antan échantillon représentatif et ce
dont tu s'aperçoit c'est que
contrairement à l'image d'épinal qu'on a
souvent des grande sociabilité ouvrière
c'est en fait surtout les cadres qui ont
le plus gros capital social et les
ouvriers ont en fait des sociabilités
qui sont davantage resserré autour de la
famille et elles sont d'ailleurs en
moins grand nombre que celle des cadres
et le capital social des plus démunis ne
vient pas du tout compenser la faiblesse
des autres types de capitaux comme on
avait pu le penser par ailleurs par
exemple dans son échantillon les cadres
ne représentent que 10 % des individus
qu'il a étudiée pourtant ils
représentent 34% des relations d'amitié
et 35% des relations de travail qu'il a
étudiée
là où c'est encore plus intéressant
c'est pour les relations familiales
parce que l'étude on montre quand même
que les relations familiales sont plus
importantes dans le monde ouvrier
là où chez les cadres effectivement les
relations de travail les relations
d'amitié peuvent avoir plus d'importance
mais même quand on prend le cas des
relations familiales bas elles sont
aussi plus nombreux sur les cadres que
chez les ouvriers
à titre d'exemple c'est 10% ce cadre il
concentre 24% des relations de parenté
et 23% des relations de voisinage qui
ont été étudiées alors qu'alain versent
les ouvriers eux qui représentent
pourtant 35 % de l'échantillon donc sont
beaucoup plus nombreux il ne concentrent
que 20% des relations de parenté et 15%
des relations de voisinage du coup
l'auteur soutient le point de vue de
bourdieu d'un capital social qui serait
un effet multiplicateur des autres
formes de capitaux lui il parle d'un
effet boule de neige puisque en fait
avoir une relation en traîne le fait
d'en avoir une autre est en fait du coup
c'est ce qui des gens le plus de
relation qui est commune cumule le plus
de relations à la fin du coup avec
bourdieu on se retrouve avec les fesses
entre deux sièges puisque d'un côté on
abat le sociologue qui popularise la
notion de capital social mais de l'autre
côté là il dit que ça sert à rien ils
n'étudient pas bon il se trouve que on a
quand même des travaux un peu plus tard
disent qu'ils vont montrer qu'il ya
quand même bien un effet propre du
capital social
c'est notamment ce que fait michel forsé
dans une étude de 97 en utilisant les
données de l'enquêté emploi de l'insee
2994 ces données elles permettent
notamment de savoir quel a été le mode
d'obtention d'un emploi d'un échantillon
de dix mille individus
on a fait en sorte que l'échantillon
soit représentatif des personnes ayant
commencé à travailler pour leur
entreprise moins d'un an auparavant
alors dit 1000 répondants ça commence à
faire du bel échantillon si on ne court
pas sur l'analyse on peut commencer à
dire que c'est du résultat bien solide
jarre solide comme apple non va pas
faire ce van est justement ce que montre
une seule force et c'est que tout le
monde utilise son capital social il
n'est pas réservé à une partie où
l'autre de la population et il montre
justement que c'est bien souvent les
moins diplômés qui ont le plus recours
notamment parce que cela permet
d'accéder à des emplois moins précaire
que ceux trouvés par l'anpe
article 2 97 il arrive donc à mettre en
évidence qu'il ya bien un effet propre
du capital social et qu'ils jouent
toutes choses égales par ailleurs même
si dans son enquête cet effet reste
encore moins important que le niveau de
diplôme
non mais du coup en vrai il a en effet
ou pas le capital social je cite une
étude qui dit oui une étude qui dit non
et justement cette longue introduction
avait pour but d'en arriver là alors
qu'on a longtemps relégué au second plan
les effets propres du capital social
on en arrive enfin à reconnaître que le
capital social à bien un effet sur le
destin des individus et plus
particulièrement sur leur capacité à
trouver un emploi
et dans ce domaine il ya un socio
économiste américain qui s'est intéressé
à ça avant tout le monde et qui
considérait ans comme une méga rockstar
dans la sociologie des réseaux sociaux
et ce chercheur c'est mark granovetter
et sa fameuse théorie de la force des
liens faibles
quoi que je dise un truc non mais c'est
bon j'ai fini l'intro là tu peux envoyer
générique pas ok bon bah alors je sais
pas moi comment tu les envoies ton
génériques
[Musique]
alors granovetter c'est un sociologue
américain né en 1943 il est aujourd'hui
professeur à l'université de stanford si
l'officier encore et c'est une référence
incontournable de la sociologie
économique parce qu'ils développent
notamment la théorie de l'encastrement
en anglais ils appellent ça un bd de
metz son point de vue c'est de montrer
que loin d'être une partie autonome du
champ social les relations économiques
sont profondément encastrée dans les
relations sociales
donc contrairement aux modèles de
l'acteur rationnelle l'homo economicus
utilisé par les économistes ce qui
montre c'est que toutes les relations
économiques et notamment les relations
sur le marché de l'emploi ne doivent pas
être mise à part mais bien étudié au
sein même des relations sociales et
c'est bien souvent par son article de
1985 sur la notion d'encastrement
condate la naissance de la nouvelle
sociologie économique style
alors oui mais ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est pas son travail sur la
notion de castres mans c'est son travail
sur la notion de réseaux sociaux qui a
donné lieu à un article
le tracé l'ebre publié en 1973 qui
s'appelle la force des liens faibles
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire mais
rien que le titre déjà il claque
comment
contrairement à bourdieu lui ce qu'ils
pensent et que les réseaux sociaux est
donc le capital social n'a pas juste un
effet multiplicateur sur les formes de
capitaux déjà existant mais joue bien un
rôle indépendant sur le destin des
individus et notamment sur leur capacité
à trouver un emploi
ce chiot chaude à people to be coming
from the stunning semaine bouliste walid
mais ont dû comme il vient de le dire
son étude porte principalement sur des
travailleurs qualifiés si ç'avait été en
france un sort et et les groupes des
cadres des professions intermédiaires
après pas mal de travail préparatoire il
se constitue donc un échantillon de 256
cadres et ceux dont il s'aperçoit c'est
que parmi son échantillon ils étaient
56% donc bien plus que la moitié à avoir
réussi à trouver un travail grâce à leur
réseau social
donc déjà ça semble confirmer pas mal
l'hypothèse selon laquelle le réseau
social aurait un rôle important à jouer
sur le statut des individus mais même si
cette donnée était déjà intéressante en
soi elle avait besoin d'être étudiée
plus finement pour réellement comprendre
les modes d'obtention de leur travail
par cette population en faisant passer
ses entretiens granovetter il s'aperçut
que les relations qui avait permis aux
individus de trouver leur emploi eh bien
elle était assez particulière pour
terminer mieux en fait ce qu'il a fallu
mettre en évidence c'est que tous les
liens sociaux que nous entretenons n'ont
pas ni la même force ni la même
importance
il a donc décidé de faire entrer une
dimension supplémentaire dans son étude
la force des liens
il définit la force d'un lien comme la
synthèse de quatre indicateurs la durée
de la relation l'intensité émotionnelle
de la relation l'intimité du lien entre
les deux
du et finalement le type et le nombre de
services que se rendaient les personnes
entre elles et en regardant tous ces
éléments il classe les différents liens
en deux catégories d'un côté les liens
forts caractérisée par des relations
longues intime intense émotionnellement
et avec un grand nombre d'interactions
entre les individus et de l'autre les
liens faibles caractérisée par des
relations de courte durée plus intense
émotionnellement peu intime et avec un
petit nombre de réciprocité entre les
individus les individus se retrouvent
donc soit avec des liens forts des liens
familiaux par exemple un frère une soeur
soit avec des liens faibles en collègue
de travail ou un pote de potes par
exemple est-ce que les chatons ça compte
dans les liens forts
bah ça va dépendre à ce que vous avez
une relation intime et réciproque
ah bah oui on fait tout ensemble eh ben
je crois que tout le monde va être ravi
d'apprendre que tu chies dans une
litière
bon après avoir classé tout son
échantillon selon ses modalités
il s'aperçoit que les individus qui
trouvent du travail grâce à leur réseau
c'est presque systématiquement grâce à
des liens faibles les liens faibles sont
donc beaucoup plus efficace que les
liens forts pour trouver un emploi
et c'est donc l'explication du titre de
l'article la force des liens faibles
ça fait quand même hyper classe ans il
n'y a pas à dire les américains ils
savent trouver des noms d'articles
l'explication de ce phénomène est en
fait assez simple et granovetter passe
par la théorie des graphes pour
l'expliquer simplement cette partie là
vous la comprendrez sûrement mieux si
vous êtes déjà familier de la façon
qu'on a de représenter graphiquement les
réseaux sociaux et que j'avais déjà
présenté dans la dernière vidéo
cela dit rester là vous verrez c'est pas
sorcier vous avez quand même assure ou
sinon ce que vous faites c'est que vous
faites pause vous allez vous faire un
thé puis vous revenez regarder les 40
minutes de l'épisode précédent en
n'oubliant pas de mettre en pouces en
l'air ça fait toujours plaisir
subjugué par tant de brillance vous
apercevez que vous avez oublié de voir
votre thé donc vous allez le réchauffé
en en profitant pour vous admirez dans
le reflet du micro ondes
puis vous revenez poursuivre cette vidéo
quand on veut représenter le réseau
social d'un individu on représente les
individus par des points et les liens
entre ces individus par des traits qui
renie ses points par exemple ici à est
en relation avec b c et d c et d sont
aussi en relation entre eux donc les
trois nous forment une clique et on a
simplement b qui n'est pas en relation
avec les autres îles en relation
uniquement avec à ce qui fait que à
forme un pont entre baie et le reste du
réseau
une arête constitue un pont quand il
permet de relier deux parties distinctes
du réseau en gros s'il est un passage
obligé pour passer d'un point à un autre
ici à est le seul de ce réseau à être en
contact avec b ce qui fait que le lien
entre a et b est tampon puisque c'est le
seul moyen d'accéder à b dans ce réseau
qui est évidemment un réseau extrêmement
simplifiée et pour finir puisque
granovetter distingue les liens forts et
les liens faibles on peut représenter va
entrer plein les liens forts et en
pointe sig et les liens faibles
voilà c'est pas plus compliqué que ça là
où ça devient intéressant c'est que
granovetter va dire que ça
c'est une configuration de réseau
impossible ils appellent ça lui atrium
et non mais comment ça pète
la triade interdite c'est vrai que celle
là elle sonne bien tu ce à quoi ça me
fait penser
[Musique]
assez sympa mais j'avais quand même
réussi à pas utiliser de contenus
copyrightés jusqu'à maintenant on a tu
t'en fous tu monétise pas toute façon
c'est pas faux quoi tu sais pas ce que
ça veut dire monétiser bon alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que cette
triade elle n'est pas interdite au sens
normatif elles interdites au sens
statistique ce que ça veut dire c'est
que c'est quasiment impossible qu
apparaisse une forme de réseau comme
celle ci parce que si à partage un lien
fort avec b et c ben il ya très fortes
chances que b et c est entre eux un lien
fort ou à minima un lien faible
il est très hautement improbable que a
est un lien fort avec b et c est que ben
a b et c n'est pas le lien du tout elle
est là l'explication parce que dans
cette triade
on a quand même deux points de passage
qui sont obligés si on veut bien faire
circuler l'information
et si elle est impossible et par voie de
conséquence il n'y a que les liens
faibles qu'ils peuvent jouer le rôle de
pont dans un réseau d'individus nous le
fait que les liens faibles sont
effectivement les plus efficaces parce
que ce sont eux qui nous permettent de
sortir de notre réseau de jouer le rôle
de pont et du coup pas d'accéder à des
informations auxquelles on n'aurait
jamais eu accès si on était resté dans
le cadre de nos liens forts
[Musique]
alors l'hypothèse de la force des liens
faibles de gars novateur elle a été
testé plusieurs fois empiriquement en
particulier dans les années 80 par le
sociologue noah friedkin qui a étudié
les réseaux de grands professeurs de
biologie donc ce qu'il a fait c'est que
il a étudié le réseau social de
professeur de biologie d'une grande
université
donc il a regardé qui se connaissaient
qui se connaissaient pas et c est dans
son étude
il a relevé onze pont donc qui permet de
faire le lien entre des individus qu'ils
ne se connaissaient pas et dans tous les
cas il s'est aperçu que chacun de ses 11
ponts étaient tous constitués de liens
faibles ce qui semble donc validée
empiriquement l'hypothèse de quart no
better la théorie de la force des liens
faibles de créneaux vetter elle a
immédiatement connu un très large succès
dans les années 70 et elle a suscité un
très grand nombre de débats et de
travaux soit pour en éprouver
empiriquement les hypothèses comme on
l'a vu avec friedkin un peu plus haut
soit pour essayer d'élaborer une théorie
structurale un peu plus large des
réseaux sociaux dans cette veine là le
travail le plus connu c'est celui de
ronald burt dans les années 90 qui
débouche sur la formulation des trous
structuraux alors je vais pas m'étendre
du tout sur le sujet ici parce que il se
trouve que j'en ai justement beaucoup
parlé dans ma dernière vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux dans game of thrones
donc si vous voulez en savoir plus je
vous invite à vous référer directement à
cette vidéo là où sinon ce que vous
faites c'est non c'est bon ils ont
compris là on va pas y passer trois
heures sur la cloche pour aller vite les
trous structuraux ce sont justement ces
personnes qui servent de pont entre deux
réseaux qui sont les passages obligés et
qui permettent justement de faire
circuler l'information d'une partie du
réseau à un autre ce qu'on avait montré
dans la dernière vidéo c'est justement
que john snow a une position tout
particulière dans le réseau parce que il
joue le rôle de trous structurale et là
maintenant vous savez que la notion de
trop structurale elle découle en droite
ligne des hypothèses de granovetter sur
la force des liens faibles
[Musique]
bon
alors il va quand même falloir nuancé
certaines choses parce que je voudrais
pas que vous alliez la fausse impression
que pour trouver un job la seule
solution ce soit de multiplier les potes
de potes sur facebook parce qu'il faut
aussi souvent réunir d'autres conditions
pour que ça marche et tes amis d'amis
ils vont pas forcément aidé à trouver un
job
déjà la première limite c'est que la
force des liens faibles bas ne marche
pas partout
si elle est très vrai aux états unis
c'est beaucoup moins le cas au royaume
uni où le recrutement se fait beaucoup
plus par annonce et ça marche pas non
plus dans des pays comme l'espagne où
pour le coup là ce sont les liens forts
qui sont véritablement plus important
pour sa cdu a plein de facteurs sur
l'organisation de l'état et du marché du
travail que je vais pas développer ici
mais bon il faut que vous ayez ça en
tête
en france on est dans une situation un
peu intermédiaire ou le recrutement par
cooptation à moins d'importance aux
états unis mais il joue quand même un
rôle non négligeable
ensuite il ya aussi une différenciation
selon les sexes rappelez-vous dans
l'échantillon de départ y avait que des
hommes et ce qu'on s'aperçoit après
vérification c'est que ça marche
beaucoup moins bien pour les femmes qui
ont tendance à davantage se passer par
des annonces ou à des candidatures
spontanées que par la cooptation et
après si c'est un effet qui se vérifie
bien pour les cadres c'est beaucoup
moins vrai pour les ouvriers qui pour le
coup utilisent le plus souvent des liens
forts ce qui les emmènent justement à
rester dans un univers qui restent
proches de leur cadre familial ça va
être par exemple travaillé dans la même
usine que papa du coup ça nous permet
pas de s'extraire de son réseau initial
ouais donc en gros ton truc ça marche il
terrain hétérosexuels 6 blancs vivant
aux etats unis pas complètement mais il
ya un peu de ça ouais et en plus ça
marche encore mieux si tu fais partie
des hauts revenus
de fait dans l'étude de granovetter on a
étudié que les individus qui changeait
de travail volontairement
de fait les gens qui changent de travail
c'est que s'ils espèrent avoir un
travail mieux rémunéré ou plus
intéressant que ce qu'ils ont déjà
ils vont pas changer de travail si c'est
pour avoir un truc moins bien
du coup deux par la sélection de
l'échantillon se retrouve déjà deux
bases pas avec des gens qui prennent le
premier travail venu simplement pour
pouvoir bouffer mais avec des gens qui
ont le temps de se constituer le réseau
suffisant pour avoir un travail qu'ils
espéraient ou du moins qui préfère celui
qu'ils ont déjà
du coup ceux dont on s'aperçoit c'est
que les individus qui utilisent
réseau social pour trouver un emploi
c'est à dire qu'ils ont le temps la
masse un réseau social suffisant
ils sont sur représentés parmi les hauts
revenus pour reprendre les données de
granovetter je vous rappelle on avait
cinquante six pour cent des individus de
son échantillon qui avait trouvé un
emploi grâce à leur réseau social
mais quand on les classe selon leur
niveau de rémunération ce dont on
s'aperçoit c'est que les personnes qui
gagnent le plus haut revenu
ils sont 76% à avoir trouvé leur emploi
grâce à leurs liens faibles
un dernier élément qu'il met aussi en
évidence c'est le temps passé pour se
constituer un réseau
ils montrent que les personnes qui ont
effectivement réussi à atteindre des
postes élevés grâce à leur réseau social
ils partagent aussi des caractéristiques
sur le temps passé dans les différentes
entreprises
ce qu'il remarque c'est que ceux qui
sont dans leur entreprise depuis très
longtemps
bah ils se sont un peu sédimenter et ils
connaissent personne dans les autres
entreprises dont ils peuvent pas
utiliser leurs réseaux pour sortir de
leur entreprise al'inverse les personnes
qui sont là depuis pas longtemps depuis
quelques mois jusqu'à deux ans ben ils
se sont pas encore assez d'expérience
pour s'être constitué un réseau et du
coup ce qui arrive le mieux à optimiser
la constitution et l'utilisation du
réseau
c'est ce qui reste entre 2 à 5 ans dans
la même entreprise avant d'essayer d'en
sortir
mais du coup si on s'est fait licencier
au bout de trois mois parce qu'on a
organisé un laser game dans l'open space
mais qu'au passage on s'est fait plein
de copains savon ou pas bah pas vraiment
parce que dans ce cas là il ya de fortes
chances que les gens se rappellent de
toi pour organiser leur fête
d'anniversaire mais pas tellement pour
te proposer un job
ah ouais c'est qu'on est sinon youtuber
ça paye
je sais pas je te dirai si j'en croise
un du coup ce qu'il faut retenir de
cette histoire c'est que pour que la
force des liens faibles soient vraiment
effective il faut quand même respecter
un certain nombre de conditions
[Musique]
bon ben on est pas mal là je pense que
ça va être le moment de faire un petit
résumé la notion de capital social même
si plusieurs sociologues dont pierre
bourdieu l'ont mise en avant elle a
longtemps été ignorée par les
sociologues qu'ils ne considéraient pas
qu'elle pouvait avoir un effet propre
sur la position sociale des individus
ont considéré que le capital social
n'avait pas vraiment un effet propre
mais qu'il avait plutôt un effet
multiplicateur des capitaux culturel et
économique déjà possédé par les
individus mais dans son article de 1973
intitulé la force des liens faibles le
sociologue américain mark granovetter
montre que non seulement le capital
social est important pour trouver un
travail
mais il ajoute en plus une dimension
supplémentaire à l'analyse en entrant
que c'est en particulier les liens
faibles qui permette réellement d'avoir
accès à une information nouvelle est de
réussir à tirer son épingle du jeu en
termes de recherche d'emploi justement
parce que les informations qui arrivent
par le biais des liens forts sont
souvent redondants granovetter montrent
qu'il ya bien un effet propre du capital
social puisque 56% des personnes de son
échantillon ont trouvé leur emploi grâce
à leur réseau et ce chiffre montre même
à 76% pour les très hauts revenus
cependant on a aussi pointé certaines
limites de la force des liens faibles
parce que l'efficacité du réseau social
pour trouver un emploi dépend aussi très
fortement de l'organisation du marché du
travail et il se trouve qu'il est moins
efficace dans d'autres pays pour les
femmes ou pour les milieux sociaux les
moins favorisés du coup on est quand
même en droit de se demander si
finalement c'était pas fondées de
considérer le capital social comme un
effet multiplicateur des autres formes
de capitaux puisqu'il ne semble jamais
marcher aussi bien que pour les hommes
blancs de vos revenus et finalement même
si tout le monde utilise son capital
social pour accéder à des ressources
ce sont principalement les liens faibles
qui compte et ceux dont on s'aperçoit
facilement c'est que ce sont largement
les cadres donc ceux qui ont le plus
gros capitale économique et le plus au
capital culturel qui se constitue le
plus facilement un réseau de liens
faibles des connaissances grâce au
travail ou des amis d'amis
il n'est donc pas étonnant de constater
que ce sont
qui tire le plus grand partie de leur
capital social est de fait on voit même
se poser plus largement un problème
d'inégalité d'accès aux emplois les
mieux rémunérés puisque comme on l'a
montré c'est précisément pour ces
emplois qu'on fait le plus appel au
réseau social pour embaucher et comme on
a toujours dans notre réseau social des
individus qui nous ressemble on semble
voué à tourner avec le même type
d'individu pour le même type d'emploi
granovetter a bien mis ce problème en
évidence et il pense qu'une solution qui
passerait par plus de discrimination
positive pour être à la fois faciles à
mettre en place et très efficace et que
ça permettrait de contrecarrer l'effet
auto références et des réseaux
personnels pour le recrutement des
cadres
je lui laisse donc les derniers mots
pour expliquer sa façon d'envisager
d'éventuelles solutions fttx du hors jeu
[Musique]
et voilà cet épisode de sociaux
classiques est maintenant terminée
j'espère qu'il vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce vers le
haut à vous abonner à mettre la cloche
si ce n'est pas déjà fait je suis désolé
si vous êtes frustrés par mon rythme de
publication j'adorerais moi aussi sortir
des vidéos plus souvent mais je doit
équilibrer ma vie professionnelle avec
ma vie sur youtube ce qui fait que je
fais mes vidéos sur mon ton libre et du
coup j'ai jamais le temps mais c'est pas
par manque d'idées ou par manque d'envié
en tout cas je vous fais des bisous
c'est à vous retrouver dans pas trop
longtemps pour une prochaine vidéo
prenez soin de vous ciao
[Musique]